hello it's me layer Heil pan and a
welcome back to my channel don't forget
to hit the subscribe button and hit the
bell see you get notified every single
time that I post drop a comment below so
you can tell me what topics you want to
hear next week and if you enjoy the
video then just give it a like this week
we're joined with rapper and political
commentator zoobi who's gonna give us
his thoughts on working from home
building your own business being
entrepreneur and the fear of failure
[Music]
[Applause]
zyy be great to have you on the show how
are you doing today very well thanks
Leia how are you I'm doing good thank
you now I wanted to invite you on today
because I think so much is happening
right now and I think people are gonna
need to start innovating people are
gonna start needing to think you know
how can I make a living from home
because right now we are all stuck at
home and people just don't know how long
it's gonna be for you freeze on who you
know you have your podcast you make your
own music and we have a book so I really
just want your advice and the people who
are thinking how can I make a living
from home what advice would you give
them Wow okay so the first thing I would
say and this this goes beyond just
making a living from home this goes to
make making a living in general and just
a good way to sort of see the world is
to think about what you can offer to
other people think about what other
people need what other people want and
see if you have a skill and ability a
talent something that you can do whether
that's a product or a service or perhaps
something that you can learn that you
can offer to fulfill that demand I mean
there are three areas beyond basic
survival where you know everything tends
to sort of fall into which I would say
our health wealth and happiness so those
are three areas where there's you know
an infinite demand and it doesn't matter
how many people are doing something if
you look at any area it looks like it's
um it looks like it's saturated you know
like how many million how many musicians
exist in the world how many authors
exist how many podcasts any any business
you can do this for any service any
business and it's weird because
sometimes people will be like all but
loads of people are already doing that
and it's like well doesn't that go for
literally everything there's like 7 and
1/2 billion people in the world or not
we're not all gonna have a totally
unique job or career but there's always
something that you can offer to people
or just give them a different angle on
it so for example with myself you know
there's of course you know everything I
do started with my music but last year I
released my first book which was a
fitness book strong advice zoo bees
guide to fitness for everybody
and you know I had people I still get
people who are like oh you know there's
so many fitness books out there like why
do we need another one and I'm like well
the obesity rates about you know no
forty percent or something so it's not
like oh everyone already knows that you
know you can just go on the internet
online it's like yeah well you can go
online and find out how to get out of
debt too but that doesn't change the
fact that tons of people are in debt you
know it's like so and sometimes you know
every in in theoretically it's like no
new books need to be written no new art
needs to be created no new music needs
to be made but human beings have an
insatiable desire for you know
everything and you might be able to
reach different people than another
person is able to reach you may have may
be able to just package the message in a
way that resonates with people in a way
that it doesn't for someone else and you
know we're all unique and we've all got
something to offer if you you know
assuming somebody already has a job or a
career what you're doing most people
don't think about it this way but what
you're already doing in your job or your
career is you are adding value to
people's lives you're improving people's
lives in some way so a lot of people
think like okay how can I make money and
I think that's the wrong way to think
about it I think a much better question
is how can I help people right or what
do people need what can I offer to
people that day value because if people
value something then they will pay for
it that is literally how the world works
that's how capitalism works there's
nothing that you pay for that you don't
value or there should be very little
right you know I don't know what's a
mouse bad thing for me personally a lot
of the time before I do something it can
be quite off-putting honey if you think
well there's already so many podcasters
already so many books so many rappers
but I think it's quite an
entrepreneurial thing to do to say you
know what I'm just gonna build my own
thing so can anyone be an entrepreneur
because I think that word frightens
people and so do you think it's
something that any
kind of cheap or some people just born
that way I think most people who are
entrepreneurs are somewhat born that way
I think everybody has a you know I don't
think it's a binary thing I think people
have different degrees of
entrepreneurialism in them some people
you know might be 90% entrepreneur you
know 10% I don't know what the what's
the opposite of an entrepreneur you know
you know whereas some people you know
are much better in a situation where
someone else is showing them what to do
and it's very structured and it's very
clear and you know lower risk and
whatever and some people are much more
attuned to that but that same person you
know even if you've only got 5%
entrepreneur and you you could probably
still sell a few things on eBay or you
know do some online tutoring or coaching
it whatever your special yeah exactly
you know that's probably something that
you can do there and if you can do it to
any degree then it means that you can
expand it and you can grow it you know
in terms of making money online like
this is something that I am actually
relatively new to I mean the vast
majority of my career was you know very
much based in the real world right going
out there in the real world and meeting
people and selling my CDs and my
merchandise and doing pop-up shops all
around the country and everything it's
only in the past twelve months that a
lot of stuff has really shifted online
for me with the podcast and the e-book
and everything so I'm still very much
learning I don't consider myself an
expert but I understand the sort of
fundamentals of it and you know like I
said it really comes down to giving
people what they want and if you're
looking for ideas then anytime you hear
somebody say something like oh I wish
there was or I need or I want or
wouldn't it be cool if they're about to
give yeah they're about to give you a
business idea it doesn't mean that
you're the person to execute it but
anytime someone saw wouldn't it be cool
if such-and-such existed oh I wish that
this was different and it's like those
are all business ideas and so once you
attune your brain
to see that and to see opportunities
where other people just see you know
challenges or roadblocks then that's
really the way entrepreneurs think sure
I guess you know just like you said
staying you know tuning your brain so
you can really find that gap in the
market find out what people really want
but I think for people sometimes they
have so many different loves and so many
different joys or sometimes they don't
know what they love and you're obviously
very much into your fitness so how did
you you know sort of figure out what I
like fitness and I like politics and I
like music you know find out what the
thing is because I think I chat to a lot
of people and people just like I don't
know what I want to do I don't know what
I like I don't know you know how do
people kind of zoom in on that it's a
good question for me it was relatively
easy I don't love politics by the way
but uh no it's okay it's a misconception
people have I think people think I like
politics I'm away more than I actually
do so for me it was fairly straight
forward because I've been into these
things since my teen years so I already
knew I love music I already knew I was
into fitness I mean I don't know why it
took me so long to write a fitness book
I should have done it like ten years ago
yeah yeah exactly but you know there for
a reality check
it's not like everyone is gonna just be
able to do what they like or follow
their passion per se right your passion
you know passion is important but
firstly you need to be good at something
right if your passion is football or
your passion is basketball but you suck
then you know you can't be a
professional footballer or a
professional basketball player there's
tons of people who are passionate about
you know sports or whatever but they're
you know they're they're not gonna make
a living from it however I don't know if
you are you really are you really do you
really have in-depth knowledge of the
sport you know maybe you could do a
basketball podcast maybe you could yeah
basketball YouTube channel maybe there's
some product you could offer to fans
which is relevant to that which works
but you know it comes back down to
seeing what people actually want seeing
where the
and seeing what people need ideally you
want to have something that overlaps
with what you're good at and what you're
interested in and what there's actually
a market demand for I think that's sort
of the the sort of Holy Grail you get a
lot of entrepreneurs who don't really
you know care you know that really focus
just about making money and they don't
care whether or not they have any kind
of passion for the thing and that's fine
I'm not personally that kind of person I
don't really do anything unless I want
to that's sort of how I operate in life
I don't know I don't know if that's I'll
be honest I don't know if that's great
advice for most people I think I'm a bit
of an exception in that regard but if
something doesn't move me then I'm just
not interested I'm sure there's plenty
of ways you know I know I know there are
plenty of other ways I could I could
make money but though I want I'm I care
about making money in a way that I enjoy
and that I actually like and that I can
do long term and doesn't really feel
like work you know what I do feels like
work sometimes but for the most part I'm
I'm very happy I have a lot of autonomy
I kind of just do I kind of just do what
I want and you know that they can be
happy so you know I agree what's the
point of doing something which doesn't
really motivate you um no totally with
you on that one but I think um there's a
lot of stuff that people can do from
home but there's also some stuff that
people would say well you know I can't
do this from home so in your opinion can
you do anything from home do we just
need to get more creative or do you sort
of have to accept well you know there
are some things which kind of can't be
done but from him you can't do
everything you know if you're if you
work in the construction industry and
you make buildings you can't do that
from home if you're a farmer and you
need to go out in a field and do stuff
then you can't do that from home any
kind of you know manual labor that's you
know maybe you can maybe build some you
know keyed you could do some degree of
carpentry or something like that from
home but there's a lot of stuff that you
cannot do from home and you know we I
don't want
even I don't even think a future where
everybody works from home would even be
a good thing I think in some people's
brain that sounds quite exciting I think
that would actually be awful so ya know
not everything can be done online and
shouldn't be we do still need people in
the real world to do a lot of real world
face-to-face stuff and there's no real
total substitute for meeting somebody in
person and actually being able to see
them and communicate you know what we're
doing right now is great Skype is great
zoom is great everything but um you're
always gonna every every degree of
separation you move away from being face
to face with another human being you're
gonna lose some nuance in the in the
conversation
and some of you okay so I studied at
Oxford University I did computer science
I graduated in 2000 and while
wow it's a while ago now I graduated I
graduated 2007 I graduated I actually
worked in the corporate world I took one
year out and I did my music full-time
for one year and then I worked in the
corporate world from 2008 to 2011 I was
actually a management consultant for a
very big consulting company and then
November 2011 I left to pursue my music
full-time and I've been full-time
self-employed independent since November
2011 so what I've done has grown and
expanded it used to just be purely the
music now I'm kind of like a rapper
slash lots of other things but um yeah
that's that's how it happened I think
the people that's always one of their
biggest concerns so what advice would
you give to them you know
it can be quite doing you don't know
when you're gonna be able to you know
monetize on whatever it is you're
building
I should be monetizing before you even
are considering leaving any full-time
employment I mean keep in mind that when
I left my job I'd already released three
albums and I already had fanbase I'd
already performed across the UK in a few
different countries so I wasn't I wasn't
at ground zero right it wouldn't be wise
for me to do that so you already want to
have money coming in from whatever it is
you're planning on doing I think it's
really honestly I think stupid to
totally cut off one income source to
jump into something with both feet where
you have no idea you haven't even tested
it yet you don't have any customers yet
you don't even know what you're doing
yet you want to build that up until it's
I don't know but I don't really really
want to give a number or a percentage
but you know maybe you want to be
earning enough from your side project or
side business that is I don't know some
percentage I don't know fifty percent
for some people would even say a hundred
percent of the salary you are already
making before you want to jump into that
I'd say maybe you know as a you know as
a random guess I'd say maybe around
fifty percent it would probably be a
pretty strong indicator that oh okay
like if you give this all your full-time
energy then you know you are confident
you can make a living from that it also
depends on your life stage right you
know part of why I did that is cuz it
was it was early for me right you know
my early 20s it's like cool I have no I
have no dependents no you know I have no
I have no children I'm not married I
don't have I don't have a mortgage I
don't have and you know like whatever as
long as I can keep myself alive and keep
myself afloat then I'm good to be honest
um I still kind of feel that way you
know it won't be like that forever right
because people go through different life
stages and the importance and priorities
do have to change as their
responsibilities change and I wouldn't
want to I wouldn't want to I wouldn't
give the same advice to a you know a 19
year old who is just totally you know
has no strings
yeah I know strings tied to hem versus
someone who's like 42 and has three kids
and is married and has a mortgage or two
you know like it's a it's a different
situation so um yeah it's a relative and
I think I think it sounds obvious but
it's not necessarily you know before you
leave a full-time job and I guess even
if you are 19 or 20 or whatever it is if
you leave a full-time job I guess you
know to build something else and make
sure you have that backup where you're
able to monetize it and before you leave
even it does sound obvious but I not a
lot of people I think would think that
way and I also talk to a lot of people
about creating their own content and I
find one of the biggest issues or
hurdles that people come across is being
concerned about what other people think
about that oh yes and I think you know
that's just one of the biggest things
and you're not you I guess you think
don't you know a lot of politics but you
are opinionated on Twitter and you do
obviously come under a lot of attack
from a lot of your opinions so to say
that how do you do with caring or guess
not caring what people think of you Wow
it's a long journey you know like I said
I've been I've been making music for
over 10 years so as a musician as an
artist as anyone who puts stuff out
there to the public you are always going
to be open to both praise and criticism
and you're never going to get one
without getting the other so from 18
onwards I was already you know just like
I was building up reps in the gym and
getting stronger I was dealing with you
know both the positives and negatives of
having people know who you are and
recognize you whether that's online or
publicly or whatever you know both the
positive and the negative so over time I
built up a very very thick skin I mean
people a lot of one thing people don't
always know about my story especially
people who discovered me recently is you
know I used to just travel around the UK
selling my CDs on the street so I've
sold over 25,000 albums like hand to
hand face to face so to sell 25,000
albums can you imagine how many people
said no or how many people so when it
comes to like you know Twitter or
someone you know writing it mean YouTube
comment I'm like
you know the I've already dealt with
this stuff for over a decade so there's
very little anybody can say and also
it's about you know whose opinions you
should even care about right I care
about what my friends think about me I
care about what my family thinks about
me I care about what my you know
supporters and genuine fans think about
me outside of that you know and it's
taken it's taken a while for me to reach
the stage but outside of that I don't
really care like I really don't care
like if it if making twenty people hate
me makes another 200 love me then go
ahead you know I'll take those odds and
I don't you know and I know what's in my
heart and I'm not like I'm not like a
hateful person I'm not some kind of like
you know radical extreme person or
whatever so it's just like whatever like
I'll just be me and you know however
many people know you the more people
know you the more people are going to
love you and the more people are gonna
hate you or think that they hate you
that's the thing it's like a lot of
these people like you know where when I
do get that it's um you know especially
when people go with the personal attacks
and things it's like I think they hate
who I they hate who they think I am they
don't actually hate me it's like you've
never met you never met me you don't
know me we've never had a conversation
whatever you maybe just saw like one
statement literally literally one
statement and you tried to form an
entire opinion on who I am as a human
being outside of this and you know I
Know Who I am like anyone who knows me
knows who I am so I'm not a you know and
for me personally it's easier to deal
with because of my natural personality
I'm extremely low in your autism which
means that I'm very insensitive to
negative emotion yeah I yeah I'm in the
bottom two percent of the entire
population of this particular I've done
like an in-depth personality test
so it basically mean if it's oh yeah
it's got its pros and it's cons I mean
generally to me I use it very much as a
pro but um you know it means I can find
it quite difficult to empathize with
certain things so like I'm essentially
like immune to de prayer ID and stuff
like that but that also means that I can
find it very very difficult to
understand it when other people
you know maybe maybe have it or if
there's a situation going on and people
are like freaking out or worried or
panicking or situation right now for
example and I'm kind of the one who's
like that's all right you know like
crystals yeah stuff not like very
chilled you know it's not that I don't
care or that I'm not like whatever I'm
just not mentally wired in that way so
that that's a factor it's that plus the
fact that I've literally had like
training you know just through yeah a
rejection horrible comments people just
being mean to me irrationally for no
reason whatever and you know and
ultimately the positive is so much more
you know like I do I do have haters
whatever but for every hater I
legitimately have like probably fifty
fans so you know again I'll take those
odds it's just kind of what it's just
what happens yeah absolutely I mean I
see you always post like the nice
inspirational comments that you get and
people saying I thank you so much to
your book it turn my life around
and so you know it sounds absolutely
worth it just finally I'm a big topic I
just quickly want to end on is the fear
of failure and your comfort zone because
I think that's another main reason why
people don't go and chase their dreams
essentially so what are your thoughts on
the failure I had people tackle that and
what does it mean to remain in your
comfort zone because a lot of people say
greatness cannot be achieved from your
conversation yeah honestly it's actually
the same question as you asked before
because the reason people fear failure
is because they fear judgment and
ridicule from other people there's no
greater human fear than fear of judgment
from others it's the it's there you know
more people are afraid of public
speaking than afraid of death that's
because people are afraid of people you
know they're afraid of what other people
are gonna gonna say to them or think
about them or whatever and really you
should never let never let a stranger
especially someone who you don't even
know or you know some something out and
ether control what you you know don't
ever let that that stop you from doing
what you're doing right why should why
should a Twitter avatar with eight
followers be able to have any control
whatsoever over my life and my actions
right it doesn't make any sense they
shouldn't so
ultimately you know a good thing to do
is to think of the sort of what's the
worst that can happen scenario and
oftentimes though what's the worst that
can happen thing is is really not that
big you know especially in this day and
age the things people who have get
freaked out about you know public
speaking starting a YouTube channel like
doing a video or what it's like you know
the worst that happens is like people
don't watch it or I hate or someone
writes a mean comment and it's like okay
is that gonna is that gonna kill you
right is that gonna physically harm you
or put you at risk or something it's
like no it's not so yeah that's that's
kind of my thought on it like I get I do
get a lot of people who like comment on
my bravery which I get but I sort of
find funny because I'm like look I'm not
brave like I'm not I'm not a I'm not in
the military I'm not getting bullets
shot at me I'm not a fireman I'm not
going to know like burning buildings and
lifting people like I'm not so I
understand it but at the same time in
terms of what I personally consider
bravery like true bravery I'm like nah
man I'm just like talking smack on
Twitter like that's not brave I think
I'm just being me and eating jokes and
whatever you know so that's that's the
way I think about it it's always about
it's always about reframing see we thank
you so much it's such a pleasure having
you on our channel today and I think you
know added so much value and
particularly with what's going on right
now with the pandemic so thank you so
much so there you have boobies top tips
and how to make a living doing something
that you love in a way that you love
don't forget to hit the like button if
you enjoyed the video comment comes what
topics you want to hear next week and
don't get hit subscribe button and hit
the bell to a new fight every single
time to bake